yep all eyes are gonna be on Meghan
Markel of course when she walks down the
aisle but we cannot celebrate her
fashion future without looking back on
her colorful past as we take you inside
Meghan style evolution it was ripped
jeans and a white button-down shirt on
Meghan for her first official appearance
with Harry in Toronto at the Invictus
games they were not yet engaged but the
outfit may have been making a statement
the white top actually was white by one
of her dear friends Misha no new and
that particular style of shirt is
actually called the husband shirt which
i think is a bit of a cute coincidence
the day their engagement became official
we saw the beginning of the Megan effect
that's where she wore a lesser-known
designer and the designer became in
demand overnight she was wearing a
Canadian brand called line the label and
the coat immediately sold out and really
put that brand on the map when she posed
on Hollywood red carpets Megan off and
went for a glittery outfits with
miniskirts to show off her legs
fast forward to aah after Harry the
hemlines dropped below her knee and her
outfit screams sophisticated chic she's
more designers like Hugo Boss and his
coat from the medium price to u.s. brand
j.crew she also done items from
companies based in the British
Commonwealth some of the brand's have
said that they've had trouble keeping up
with the inventory needs for the Megan
effect and that their websites have
crashed during a shoot for Good
Housekeeping in 2016
Megan shared what fashion P says we're
must-haves when she travelled just like
some really great comfy trousers simple
top the black blaze or something like
that so you just look refined definite
wear sneakers don't wear heels I always
been a great little cashmere throw so
let you stay warm on your flight and
let's talk accessories Megan likes to
rock a crossbody handbag which keeps her
hands-free for all that meeting and
greeting and she's a stiletto girl her
style of footwear is actually quite sexy
she's not afraid of a super high heel
for inches and above we see a little bit
more sultry appeal when it comes to her
Footwear choices
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]